All right.
4:45 Pacific Time. So I think
it's time to start. Thank you very much to all of
you for being here today. We really appreciate you taking the time
to share with us this session that really focuses on
one of the symptoms that we are going to argue is
particularly neglected in cancer care, and it refers to
chemosensory dysfunction or smell and taste
issues due to diagnosis, treatment, or even after
the treatment is concluded. So I am Valentina Parma.
I'm an assistant professor at the Monell Chemical Senses Center, which is
the world's only institute, only focused on the
basic research of smell and taste, and applications as well,
and I am also an adjunct assistant professor at the University of Pennsylvania
Department of Otolaryngology. I'm here with my colleagues, Dr.
Linda Barlow and Dr. Anna Bolton. They're going to introduce
themselves later on. But we welcome questions.
As you've seen, we've got candy to start.
We're a fun group, so feel free to
ask your questions and interact with us as much as you would like.
There used to be a QR code on the screen.
Maybe it's going to come back, maybe not.
In case you want to ask questions online, you can screen the QR code and
go there. For those who might be following us online,
please feel free to use that.
Otherwise, for you, please remember to go to the microphone and ask your questions
so that folks that are going to listen to us online or watch the
recording can actually hear us.
So without further ado, I'm going to start with my
talk. So thank you so much for going back to the slides.
So today, basically,
my thesis is this: Chemosensory dysfunction is common in
cancer, it is clinically meaningful, and it is
underdiagnosed and not integrated in
cancer care. And I hope with your help, we can either discuss how
to make it better and actually change a thing or two here.
All right. So I've seen it in my
household how cancer can actually change the ability to smell and
taste. I've seen it by talking to colleagues, by talking to
members and patients that are part of the Smell & Taste
Association of North America, as well as other groups that
focus on cancer. But this is not an uncommon thing.
Losing or changes in smell and taste, it's something that
it's a daily reminder that there's a cancer diagnosis in your
body.
That was not what was supposed to happen. Let's go here.
For some people, their daily coffee when they start the morning doesn't taste as
much as it used to be, and it doesn't even smell like that.
For some people, even brushing your teeth, it's kind of a
trip to a dumpster. There are distortions that are particularly
nauseating, and really remember the smell of trash or
excrements.
Even if you don't have active nausea, actually, thinking
about sharing a meal with family and friends becomes something that it's
prohibitive. And also, you might be experiencing
some metal mouth or strong bitter
experiences in your mouth. And again, this becomes a painful daily
reminder that life is not like it used to be, and this is quite
disruptive.
So chemosensory health, it's not a nice-to-have.
It actually
is underlying a lot of behaviors that are related
to survival.
We use our smell definitely to drive ourselves to food.
We use our taste to drive consumption.
And so if there are disruptions in these senses, nutrition
doesn't look like what it used to be.
One thing that might not be as known outside of the
community is that actually, if you lose your sense of smell, your relationship with
people are actually changing. So one classic
example is the newborn baby with their mom.
They're not using vision that early.
They're actually using smell to find the breast and then
lactate. But also, smell is used in the context of
mating, of relationship, of friendship.
So losing that sense changes the way we interact with people.
Another way of doing that is really taking away the enjoyment of
life. So not liking candles, not liking going out to
meals, changing the way you cook,
and also being less safe than before.
You're not able to detect whether milk could
be spoiled, and so you might drink it and get sick, or you might even not
be able to perceive a gas leak that can only be smelled.
And these are rare occurrences, but you can understand how
that knowledge that you might not be able to detect makes you feel unsafe.
And outside of the general aspects of life
that chemosensory dysfunction
has across diagnosis, there are specific aspects
that affect cancer. And so if you're not able to eat
like you used to, there is an unintentional weight loss and malnutrition risk that,
as you know, can contribute to general frailty or poor clinical
outcomes. But also to decreased tolerance of cancer
therapies. And so not being able to eat really contributes
to the options that you have in front of you.
Generally speaking, and you will see it in one of the future slides, there is
actually a substantial reduction in quality of life, broadly
speaking, that really touches people that have dysfunctions
in smell and taste, and on top of cancer.
And other than that, basically, when patients are bringing
up the idea that they have smell and taste dysfunction, they don't really find
good listening ears in their family or their friends,
nor in their clinical providers. And so this creates that feeling of
isolation, that it's really not fostering the support
system that we all want to
provide.Chemosensory dysfunction,
it's a general sentinel for a disease that it's
under-recognized more broadly. So this is not a cancer-specific
aspect. But when we start looking at data from even
representative sample, it tends to predict a cognitive decline and
conversion of cognitive decline into dementia in a vast
majority of people with Parkinson's disease and Alzheimer's disease.
We're talking about 85%, 90% of people, so it's not a
rare occurrence. It predicts a heart failure, so
those who have smell dysfunction, they have 30% to 40% higher
risk of incident heart failure. It's linked to malnutrition,
to frailty related to surgery or not, and generally speaking,
accelerated aging, as well as there's a high
correlation between people that lose their sense of smell and are
depressed, and vice versa. Those who are depressed tend to have
lower olfactory abilities, and those who lose their sense of smell are more
depressed. But also, this is specifically linked to suicidal
ideation. So it seems that losing your sense of smell
actually has a breadth of bad outcomes.
When it comes to cancer, we know that approximately 60% of
patients with cancer have or report having some
form of smell dysfunction, but 93% of people
experience taste dysfunction in the course of their disorder.
So again, this is not like a minor group of
patients. It's not a rare set of symptoms, and it's
generally unaddressed.
When we start looking at research more broadly, there are almost four and a half
million studies in PubMed just by looking at cancer in
humans, and only 0.1% includes a mention of
smell and taste. So although
it's growing, we can see that in the latest year, there's more and more
attention to this, it's still a very marginal area of
research and clinical practice that we hope can change.
Chemosensory dysfunction is often thought of as a symptom of
particularly of head and neck cancer, of course, like in the
nose, in the mouth. There are structures that allow us to
translate the chemical information into electrical signal for the brain.
And so the tumors might be there. Surgery might take out those tumors
and allow for sensory dysfunction to emerge.
But this is actually not the only case, that there's a variety of other
types of cancers at different stages across the
lifespan that actually present with smell and taste dysfunction,
alone or in association with therapy.
Chemotherapy, radiation, or surgery can all
impact in a transient way or even more permanent, like at
the end of the treatment, the appearance of chemosensory
dysfunction and permanence.
This is a problem because when we start looking at representative data on how
chemosensory dysfunction in cancer is linked to life
satisfaction, we start seeing that this becomes a
huge
symptom that reduces quality of life.
So these two graphs are taken from an
analysis run on the National
Health and Nutritional Examination Survey or NHANES,
that looks at more than 3,000 people,
again, representative samples in the US, where we find
14% reports taste dysfunction, 22% reports
smell dysfunction, and 10% reports both.
And there is a 40% reduction of
odds ratio of experiencing a satisfying life if you're
experiencing smell dysfunction and 60% if you're
experiencing taste dysfunction.
So that's a big chunk of the experience.
When we start digging a little bit into what taste dysfunction or smell
dysfunction can highlight, we can see that at least 50%
of people, based on data from Alyssa Nolden at the University of
Massachusetts Amherst,
patients that are undergoing the second or third
cycle or chemotherapy, one in two really reports that there
are changes in the way the food tastes.
And if you look at the bars in the graph, the gray bars indicate people
experiencing taste changes versus those who don't, in
black. You can see that there is a variety of GI symptoms,
constipation, feeling bloated, difficulty swallowing, weight gain, weight
loss, that is magnified in association with
taste changes,
irrespective of the cancer and the stage that they're at.
And we're trying to figure out why might we not really
look at what happens in chemosensory dysfunction.
It's not something that is traditionally part of the
clinical path, and one of the reasons might be that we don't have the words
to actually talk about smell and taste.
And so our patients, if they're not prompted, they're not really able
to
report accurately where the problem might be.
And this is a study that I conducted with a former postdoc of mine, and it's
not in the cancer space, but in general.
And we ask people, "Can you think about your awareness and your value of
different senses?" We ran this study on more than 1,000
people across 20 countries, and 62% of
people say, "If forced, I could totally give up the sense of smell." So
people don't generally have awareness and wording to detect what smell
is doing in their life and what might be the source of some
benefits from it.
But now it's the time to eat candy, and so you all have your
packets, or most of you have your packets.
If you don't, there's some in the front that you're welcome to take.
And so we're trying to dissociate here the experience of smell and
taste and flavor, and trying to see how we can help
patients that are experiencing smell and taste changes to
actually more accurately report and probe
more accurately where the problem might be.
So what I'm going to ask you to do is to take out that blue thing, like the nose
clipper, and put it on your nose.And it doesn't
hurt. It squishes a little bit. And then take one of
the jelly beans that you find
and place it in your mouth. And I would like for you to chew
that jelly bean with
your
clip on the nose.
And I would like to know what is your experience.
If you have to describe what is happening right now in your
mouth, how would you describe what you're eating?
It is muted. It is muted, I hear. But what is it?
We know these are jelly beans, so we have some priors of what
we might be tasting like.
Sweet. Somebody says sweet.
That's good.
Well, but you don't have your clip.
Oh my, I took it out. Well, that's the whole point.
So basically, what happens right now is that most of you are going to experience
something that is related to sweet, maybe sour, depending on the jelly bean that
you have. But it's really hard to pinpoint what is the
flavor that you have. So what you're experiencing right now is
taste. Sweet, sour. If we had other stimuli, it
could be umami, it could be salty. That information is
what taste is like. When you remove the clip, that's when you
start having the experience of what olfaction brings into
the flavor matrix. And so only when you remove the clip, you can say
that that might be lemon. And so you can identify which kind of sweet,
sour experience you are having. And this tells you that olfaction
plays a much stronger role than people think in describing
taste and food experiences. Right?
So I would say that it has been generally quantified that
80% of the food experience, of the flavor experience, come actually
from the nose rather than from the mouth.
But your patients are going to come to you and tell you, "I have a problem with my
food. It's my taste. I can't taste a thing." And you have to be able
to differentiate whether the problem is really in the mouth, it is in the nose, or
it is on the integration of the two.
So taste, as we said, it's not just taste, although that's the word that people
use. It could be orthonasal olfaction.
So if you were to take that jelly bean and break it in two and
smell it with your nose, that information is what is processed by the
orthonasal olfactory system. When you removed the clip,
that is retronasal olfactory information.
So you were chewing your food, and the molecules went up from
your throat up to the nose, behind the bridge of the glasses,
and the olfactory receptors were able to bind to some of
those chemicals. Taste, instead, is what we said, like this
broad painting of sweet and sour and salty and umami.
And then we have a third system, which is called the
chemesthesis, which mediates a series of
experiences related to cooling and warming or even
carbonation. So if you give one of your patients, like you
take out an alcohol wipe and you give it to your patient and say, "Smell
this. Can you smell?" Most people, even those that completely
lost their sense of smell, can actually say, "Yes, I smell something." But
that's because this alcohol activates the trigeminal system.
And so what we're really measuring there is chemesthesis rather than olfaction.
When we try to put names to the different phenotypes of what
smell and taste dysfunction look like, we can have the complete loss of the sense
of smell, so people cannot smell any odor no matter what.
They can be born with this condition, which is called anosmia, or they can
acquire it over time. In cancer, that would be generally acquired.
Hyposmia, instead, it's the reduction of the experience of
orthonasal smells or retronasal smells.
Hyperosmia, which often is linked to
chemotherapy, is the experience of hypersensitization to the
presence of odors. And so everything feels magnified,
every odor feels magnified. And then we have parosmia.
So you might remember when I talked about brushing
your teeth and going to a dumpster trip, that is
what parosmia might feel like. There's a distortion in the experience of what the
odor source should generally smell like, and people are
quite disoriented and negatively affected by
it. And by the end, we have phantosmia, which are olfactory
hallucinations. And so the idea that there is no odor
source that can give us molecule that the person experiences, but
nevertheless, the brain encodes information that comes out in the
form of a smell perceived.
Similarly, when we go to taste, we can have ageusia or a
complete loss of taste. This is very rare.
So usually the assumption is if people come to you with a taste
issue,
8 out of 10 times it's going to be a smell issue, but we need to
discriminate the two. Hypogeusia is the reduced experience of
salt, savory, sour, et cetera.
And then one of the most common issues actually comes with dysgeusia.
So distortions in smell and taste.
It comes as metal mouth or metallic taste
in the mouth, or even extreme bitter exposure.
Extreme bitter experiences to stimuli that might not be bitter
themselves. And then we have xerostomia, so a lack of
saliva, like dryness in the tongue that actually changes the way
we perceive flavor, even if the
receptors might be
intact.When we try to think
about what providers
know about chemosensory function,
what we see is that at least 15% of clinicians
are able to distinguish taste from flavors.
So they might have been exposed to one of the jelly bean tests as we
have described before, but otherwise, most people talk about
taste in general. And 44% of oncology clinicians
actually report that their patients with taste alterations tend to
experience this symptom as very important.
And so what do we do once we
can detect
smell and taste dysfunction? What can we do?
And so there's a problem with measuring it, and there's also a problem with how to
address it. Currently, we don't have pharmacological
solutions to reverse the smell dysfunction or taste dysfunction that
really works.
So what we try to do is to actually create
quick ways to change and to train clinicians.
So we ran this quick study with 38 clinicians at Fox Chase in
Philadelphia. We had 24% of them report that they
had some formal training in taste and smell, but 42%
lacked the confidence to have conversations about taste and smell changes
with their patients. What we did was to create a
podcast, like 30 minutes, try to do a little bit of education
on what is the epidemiology of chemosensory dysfunction in
cancer as well, what are the difference, much like what we've
reviewed in this talk. And just this 30-minute
session actually made them way more confident in their experience to have
conversation with their patients.
So if we were to decide how to measure smell and taste and flavor,
like in this paper, which is a consensus paper, we have more than
100 measures to do so. And so one of the things that we can
easily do and that we're trying in connection with Fox Chase is to
include in EPIC a quick question about dysgeusia or
smell dysfunction, and trying to see, across
cancer and diagnosis and over time, what is the
self-report. This is very effective when it comes to taste.
There are also some quick tests that take up to two minutes or five minutes
at most, and you can go more in-depth with the
evaluation. When it comes to taste, the solution is the best way to
assess taste function, but it's highly impractical,
so there are some taste strips that can be used.
Very quickly, there are some things that work that would symptom management like
flavor enhancement, put more salt, garlic.
Of course, the salt can have some risk with cardiovascular issues, so
we need to be mindful of that. Individualized dietary counseling has
been particularly effective whenever possible.
Clinician education helps, as well as eating cold or frozen food
using plastic utensils to reduce metal mouth.
For this, there is some
evidence that has been
validated. What did not work but is actually still suggested
in some of the patient
information that goes around is the use of zinc sulfate or general
nutritional supplements. Those actually have not been proven
through meta-analysis and other papers to actually seem to work.
There are some promising treatment like lactoferrin supplementation
to reduce metal mouth or liposomal spray to reduce
xerostomia. We need, of course, further research.
And there has been the attempt to use taste and smell training,
meaning that the repeat exposure to different tastes and smells over
time, like twice a day for six months, to change the
experience.
And also adaptation of oral nutritional supplements
seems to help some patients with specific taste distortions.
What I want to leave you with is chemosensory dysfunction is prevalent,
impactful, and under-treated. Even if no cure is available, we
can validate, at least patients are not going to think they're crazy, and
provide evidence-based symptom management that can improve quality
of life in the short term.
We can integrate any form of chemosensory dysfunction screening in
your common clinical or research task.
That would be extremely helpful. And there is an entire
chemosensory community ready to work with you to improve the lives of patients.
And you can find this information in a-- We
created a map because we surveyed our community to let you
know what are the studies that are going on, what are they talking about, and what
they're doing, and you can download it if you scan this
QR code. You can get the podcast, you can get the information
of what the chemosensory community is doing, and you're welcome to share what
your interests are for teaming up.
So with that, I thank you all. If you have a couple of questions, I
went a bit over time, so if you have a couple of questions, that's great.
Otherwise, we can move
to the next speaker. Thank you.
Hi. This is such a fascinating topic, and I'm curious,
what reason do you think this has been so understudied?
I think the problem is awareness. This is the highest battle that we
have in the chemosensory field. As I mentioned, people are not
aware of the importance of the senses, the chemical senses,
particularly smell, and they realize it when they lose it.
And that's why it's so surprising and destabilizing, because, again, we
have reminders, multiple reminders a day of what smell
brings to our life or what taste brings to our life, and we
only catch it too late. So I think it's on us
to try to either educate or really ask the question
to patients and try to use the right words so that we
understand where the problem is and point them to the right
solutions. Currently, it's a lot of trial and error on them.
Thank you. This will influence my practice for sure.
Thank you very much. Appreciate it.
Thank you for the talk. I learned a lot.
I did not even know that this was happening until I closed
my nose. But I just wanted to ask, and I know that this was not the purpose
of your talk, but if you could comment or speculate
on the mechanisms.
What's the crosstalk between a cancer cell and basically a neuron?
So I'll ask you to wait for a second because Dr.
Barlow is going to focus all on that, and so we'll
give her the floor really soon. But thank you so much for your feedback.
Thank you.
Hi. Thank you for the talk. My question is, do you see the patients
go to places like ChatGPT to ask questions like this
and ask AI to help them deal with it?
And if so,
what have you--
That's a great question. I think chemosensory scientists
are not going to go--
AI cannot solve this problem yet because we haven't put in as
much words, because we are limited in that way.
The English language, as well as many other languages, doesn't have a lot of words
to talk sensibly about olfaction, and they confound olfaction and
taste a lot. So garbage data in,
AI is going to give us garbage data out.
And so that is still not the status where we're going
to have the best results. So patients can still get very wrong
information from AI because there's not enough material
to provide good responses out there.
Thanks for the session. I have one question that probably has not
been mentioned in your talk. Because you mentioned about one might
not work or one might be working. What about prevention?
Certain types of peripheral neuropathy, for example,
associated with taxane. Nowadays, prevention
strategies are more effective than treatment strategies.
So do you have any ideas or suggestions on this part?
Thank you.
So there are a couple of things that
can help with
chemosensory health in there. And I might,
I don't know. I think we're going a little bit...
No, we still have three minutes. Okay.
So there are some
prevention strategies. So smoking, we know it declines the sense
of smell greatly. So that is a good
suggestion, not only for chemosensory health, but more broadly.
With respect to prevention in other
proximal things, there is not a ton
out there, honestly. So we're still trying.
I think the phase in which we are in chemosensory data, and what I would like
to see from the community, is to actually try to merge together
all the data that is available and create norms and conditions that
are pathology specifics. We have plenty of studies, but they're kind
of small and maybe not representative.
But prevention is not an area that
is in focus right now. I think we're still on the
treatment outcomes part, but maybe Dr.
Bolton might talk about that a little bit more later.
Thank you.
Thank you very much. Very much appreciated all of the interaction.
Linda,
your turn.
Okay.
Great.
So,
Valentina, thank you for a number of things.
First, for setting up the session so nicely.
Second, for arranging that we got here to do this together.
And
I think there's more. There'll be more. Yeah.
Two or three.
And I'd like to thank the AACR for supporting this session
as well.
So I'm going to come at this from a very
different perspective. I'm a basic science researcher.
I interact with clinicians only when I go to the doctor, really,
and I have some colleagues and collaborators that I work with, but
I don't see patients.
But I have been motivated, my lab's work, especially for the last, I'd
say 15 years, to try and figure out how
the sense of taste is maintained through the lifespan.
And that has led us increasingly towards
understanding how many different targeted cancer therapies
actually disturb the sense of taste.
And so you are aware now that you use taste buds on the tongue
to detect sweet, sour, salt, bitter, and umami.
Maybe you got up close and personal with sweet.
But what I will tell you, and you may not be aware of, is that all the cells in
your taste buds are renewed just like your skin,
so that every two months, all those cells that detect those taste
qualities are new.
And so we're fascinated by how the sense of taste is constantly
renewing, yet perceptually so constant.
So I was told this was a CME class, and
so I had learning objectives. And
what I'd like you to appreciate by the end of this session
is to have an understanding of the normal mechanisms that
underlie taste bud cell renewal.
Understand that there are pathways that regulate taste
homeostasis that are also implicated in cancer, and then
how cancer pathways that are targeted
specifically affect different aspects of taste bud cell
turnover. And then finally, I'll introduce you to some
data or some new findings on our
approaches to develop standardized taste organoids
in both mouse and human.
So
as you're aware, taste buds are embedded in papillae on the tongue,
and these are... There we
go.So in the front of the tongue
are the fungiform papillae, and these are simple taste buds.
Each bump has a couple, a dozen or fewer taste
buds. Whereas in the back of the tongue are these more complex,
larger circumvallate and foliate papillae, and
these each house hundreds of taste buds.
Now, these are innervated by specific cranial nerves.
The front of the tongue by the branches of the seventh cranial nerve, the
geniculate ganglion, and the back of the tongue by
gustatory neurons in the nodose ganglion of the ninth
cranial nerve. Now, but regardless of where these buds are
located, they have a really comparable organization.
So they are all clusters of roughly 60 to 100
cells. They're elongate in shape, and they have access to
the oral cavity at their microvillar tips to
taste stimuli.
And the taste bud cells can be broken up into three
morphological types, one, two, and three, and those can be
further subdivided into functional subtypes.
So we know
that type one taste bud cells are thought to function like support
cells, and that they are the most prevalent with the
shortest lifespan. Type two cells can be
sweet, umami, or bitter sensing cells, depending
on the G protein-coupled receptors that they express.
And these have intermediate prevalence and intermediate lifespan.
And then the third, type three cells are known to be
sour sensors and may be high salt detectors
in the circumvallate papillae.
Now, all of these cells are renewed
rapidly, really every two months, they're all new, from
progenitors that sit at the basement membrane.
And in the circumvallate papillae in particular,
excuse me,
these cells can be identified by their expression of LGR5 as well as
other markers. And when a taste progeny is
generated from these proliferating cells, they enter the taste
bud as a post-mitotic precursor, and we can use lineage
trace to demonstrate that these sonic hedgehog
expressing cells can give rise to type one, two, or three
cells, and do so to maintain the constant
ratio of taste bud cell types within each bud that we think
are really important for maintaining the sense of taste.
Now, the other thing that these cells do, these progenitors, is they give
rise to all the cells on the surface of the tongue and in the taste papillae.
These non-taste keratinocytes are rapidly
renewed and form the bulk of the output of the progenitor cells.
So you can see that just this little organ with
60 or 100 cells, the cells have all these decisions to
make, and they must be tightly regulated.
How often to divide, how often to make a taste progeny, how
often to make a type one cell. How are the fate decisions amongst cells and buds
decided upon? How do you decide to become taste versus non-taste, et
cetera? And there's more. So you can imagine then, with all those
decisions, that it might really
make the system prone to disruption.
So we have spent the last, I would say, 10
years now, really digging into how homeostasis
is regulated at the molecular and cellular level.
And we use mice
for the power of genetics, but also because the taste system
is organized very similarly to our own, with small
differences. The fungiform papillae house only a single taste bud in
mice, and that's shown here in red in a cross-section.
But in the circumvallate papilla, there are also hundreds of taste buds, as
in human, but there's a single one in mice.
And they're innervated by the same sets of cranial nerves that innervate those same
types of buds in human.
So I'm just going to give you... Really, you could leave after I do this slide
because I'm going to tell you what I'm going to tell you that we have managed to
figure out. So here's a simplified diagram of the lineage
relationships of progenitors giving rise to
non-taste cells, and then taste progeny, and
type one, three, and sweet or bitter type two
cells.
And so we've looked at the Wnt beta-catenin pathway.
As you may be aware, the beta-catenin, the activating
mutations in this pathway are key to colorectal cancer.
And we know that Wnt beta-catenin in taste regulates the
progenitor proliferation and survival, as well as
specification of discrete taste bud cell types.
Hedgehog signaling is, again, important in taste
homeostasis. Sonic hedgehog,
activating mutations in this pathway underlie basal cell carcinoma
as well as many other cancers. And we know that
hedgehog promotes differentiation of taste buds.
And then finally, we have a recent story
about receptor tyrosine kinase signaling, which
these tyrosine
kinase inhibitors are used to inhibit certain receptor tyrosine
kinase in treatment of cancer. And this, in particular,
regulates KIT and the decision between sweet
and bitter fate.
So Danny Gaillard,
excuse me, when he was a postdoc in the lab, published a series of
studies on using genetic models of Wnt
beta-catenin, and what he found was that both
that
Wnt signaling is required for progenitor
proliferation and survival.And it's also elevated
levels of the pathway give rise to type one cells in
excess and to some degree to type two cells,
but they have no impact on sour cells.
He also did deletion experiments and showed that in the absence
of progenitor output, as that declined,
then he got a steady rundown in taste bud
cells in the different taste fields.
And importantly, when he looked at taste behavior, he found some
interesting impairments in taste behavior in mice associated
with loss of Wnt beta-catenin signaling.
Now, from clinical studies,
we know that pathway inhibitors in patients are highly
associated with dysgeusia. And I think
that's in part why many of these
drugs seem to fail in treatment before they can
be really deployed in the clinic.
And we don't really understand why a steady
rundown of taste buds causes dysgeusia
so quickly in patients, but I'll tell you one idea
that Danny had, and that is that we've known in both human
and in mice that the anterior tongue is better tuned to
sweet stimuli than bitter,
and the posterior is better tuned to bitter than sweet.
And when he knocked out the pathway, what he found is that
the taste buds in the anterior tongue began to
rapidly decline, and this correlates with a decline
in behavioral sweet sensing.
And so this caused Danny to propose at the end of this set of
studies that it could be an imbalance in
taste inputs between the front and the back of the tongue that may contribute
to patient dysgeusia when treated with Wnt inhibitors.
And so that was kind of a novel idea, and I don't know if clinicians have
any thoughts about that in terms of patient profiles.
So the next story I'll tell you about is with hedgehog signaling,
and inactivating mutations in patched
relieve inhibition on smoothened, and so that the hedgehog
pathway now is activated in the absence of ligand,
driving proliferation and tumor growth.
And so we've known for some time that small molecules that target smoothened are
very efficient at knocking down solid tumors,
including those in
basal cell carcinoma. But we also know that
these patients have high incidence of dysgeusia,
and leading to non-compliance and some of the problems that
Valentina hearkened to.
So Archana Kumari, when she was a postdoc in the
Mistretta lab some time ago, looked at what happens
histologically to the tongues of mice that are treated with this drug.
This is the Novartis smoothened
antagonist. And what she showed was that taste
buds were simply lost and that the nerve
fibers that record the sensory, for example, the seventh
cranial nerve responses to tastants were diminished.
And at the time, Archana and colleagues were
inclined to think that since hedgehog functions, the pathway functions as
a mitogen in cancer, that likewise, hedgehog
signaling likely promotes proliferation of
progenitors and thereby supports the sense of taste.
So when David Castillo Azofeifa was in the lab as a
student... He was a really good student.
David did a series of genetic experiments and combined with drug
treatment to ask this question, if hedgehog signaling is indeed
affecting progenitor proliferation.
And so he found that overexpression of hedgehog actually,
as one would expect if it drove progenitor proliferation, does not
drive
tumors to form in the tongue, but instead drives excess formation
of taste buds, which was novel.
He also showed
that genetic loss of sonic
or inhibition with smoothened blocked differentiation of
taste bud cells but didn't alter proliferation.
So that left David with this model here, where sonic
hedgehog signaling, the pathway promotes differentiation of progenitors,
and in the absence of hedgehog, the cells become non-taste epithelium.
And so the important point about this in terms of cancer therapy
is that smoothened antagonists are doing something entirely different to cancer
cells than they are to taste tissue.
And so I think that's a pretty interesting observation and
may give clinicians some
ideas about how to better
preserve taste while still
treating cancers.
So the last story I want to tell you about
concerns these tyrosine kinase inhibitors.
So they're a very large class of drugs that target receptor
tyrosine kinases, and they have a high incidence of
dysgeusia. They're used to treat a spectrum of cancers, and there's
a huge spectrum of these drugs. And we were alerted to a
particular subtype or subcategory of these
drugs by Elaine Lam, who treats patients with
metastatic renal carcinoma at our
institution. And
she uses tyrosine kinase inhibitors or TKIs
to target the VEGF receptor and PDGF-R beta receptors
that
function in vascularization of tumors.
So she uses these drugs to knock down the blood supply to
tumors.And again, these drugs have a very
high incidence
of dysgeusia. And Elaine tells me that her
patients, this is one of their number one complaints, is that they're
terminal. This is life-prolonging treatment, but their sense of
taste,
loss of it or dysgeusia is very troubling.
So
these are the three drugs that she uses as first and second-line
FDA prescribed medications for this cancer.
And
when Tina joined the lab during COVID, and Tina just
graduated,
she wanted to tackle this project to understand how it is
that anti-angiogenic TKIs cause taste
dysfunction.
And I should tell you that we know from our a lot of
expression data, transcriptomics, et cetera, that those
intended targets are not expressed in our tissue.
So the first thing that she wanted to do was understand
how these TKIs might be affecting
homeostasis. And I'll tell you about organoids in just
a moment, but she treated organoids with each of the three
TKIs, and
she only observed reductions in sweet cells,
markers of sweet cells.
And she expanded these experiments into mice
and found that mice treated with cabozantinib, one of those drugs,
have fewer sweet cells and more bitter cells.
And then she did experiments to track via lineage tracing
the genesis of new cells during treatment.
And she found that it was really the ability to make become a sweet cell that
was impeded, and
bitter cells were promoted as opposed to any kind of impact
on
taste cell survival.
And remarkably, she used taste behavioral tests of
treated mice and showed that these mice had blunted responses to
sweet, but didn't have alterations
to any other taste qualities.
And so then this is the part where
if you want to understand how we got to this part, I
can walk you through it, but you're just going to have to trust me that we came
upon the
KIT receptor tyrosine kinase as a potential
target in this context, an off target, if you will.
And Tina deleted KIT in the type II cell
precursors, and that led to a phenocopy of the drug treatment.
So we got fewer sweet cells and enhanced differentiation of bitter
cells, indicating that KIT inhibition
is likely affecting taste bud cell fate.
So here's yet another place where cancer therapies are
having an unintended effect in that while
these drugs are known to inhibit KIT and are used in that
context in other cancers, in metastatic
renal cancer, the drugs are used to target the vasculature,
and the unintended off-target
KIT is then that inhibition of that
receptor tyrosine kinase drives a shift in taste cell
fate. All right.
So those are the three stories of what we understand, and it's slow
going to do a lot of mouse experiments.
And we have, of course, always go back to in vivo experiments,
but we like to accelerate what we're doing.
And so we developed a standardized protocol building on what
Peihua Jiang at Monell, and Wenwen Ren at the time was at
Monell, had demonstrated in 2014.
We modified and standardized their protocol to
generate taste organoids from these Lgr5 taste progenitors
in mouse CVP. And so this is a mouse that expresses
GFP under the Lgr5 promoter. And you can see
we then can
take the CVP, enzymatically peel it,
dissociate, isolate the Lgr5 progenitors, and then from
there, grow these cells under a growth and
differentiation phase. And at the end of that, we have organoids that
make all the different taste bud cell types.
And in part, we leverage this tool in
Tina's paper on the KIT story that
will be published actually on Tuesday
in "Development."
So
we think organoids then provide a really nice model for
us to accelerate
potential therapies, discovering how potential therapies
might impact taste homeostasis before we get
to the clinic or to people.
Now, the other thing, though, that we
understand we're making a very large leap by
studying what's going on in mice
and making the extension that if we can demonstrate that a cellular
mechanism is perturbed by a particular therapy in a mouse, and
that leads to a taste behavioral difference,
doing the extrapolation to patient dysgeusia is a big one.
And at a minimum, we'd like to understand better if human
taste is affected at a cell molecular level in
a comparable fashion. And so we've recently been able
to obtain
circumvallate papillae from humans.
And so humans have as many as 12 circumvallate
papillae in this kind of chevron organization.
And here's one. You can see the size of it in these number five
forceps. And here are the trenches.
We don't have orientation yet on these, so we don't really know which end is which,
what's front, what's back. But when we section through and do
histology, we find we can see type II cells.
It's a general marker of sweet, bitter, umami cells, at least in
mice.And keratin-8 cells, which is expressed by all
taste bud cells.
And so this is promising that we are characterizing these
CVPs to understand their organization, and we've
recently begun experiments to identify where the
LGR5 progenitor cells might be located in
human tissue.
And
with that said then, we currently lack in
vitro models for human taste epithelium.
We simply don't have them, and they have not...
People have been trying for many, many decades,
and we have now recently been able to mince up fresh
CVPs from humans and acutely derive
taste organoids. So we're very excited about this.
So these are keratin-8 positive cells.
These are the type two cells, and this is the subset that expresses
a marker of bitter cells.
So we think that we're on our way
to developing taste organoid technology for
human taste epithelium.
And so it goes without saying, so I'll just wrap
it up really quickly here. So dysgeusia is not
monolithic.
So that's my perspective because
taste dysfunction or the taste system is perturbed
differently by different drugs, right?
And
targeted therapies might have...
They differ with drug, perhaps not with respect to the type of
cancer, but rather the therapy may be more informative,
and the impact of the drug on taste can be different than
how the drug affects cancers. And so I'd
also be curious to ask clinicians if
taste dysfunction in patients is not monolithic, and if they can
identify separate subtypes of functional
taste disruption.
And I think that if we understand better how taste is broken by these drugs,
we can come up with better ways to
mitigate that troubling side effect.
So I'll thank the lab. People in bold are people that contributed to the
work over the years. These are kind of small right now.
We're in the process of recruiting people to help us with the human work.
And this is... I've got to thank the Taste & Smell Center
at the University of Colorado,
Peter Dempsey, who's helped us get organoids going and our funding.
And I'll take questions if there's a moment.
Thank you for the talk. Very interesting. So I have a question.
I'm Monica Bisnasky, Italy.
Can you drop the mic a little?
Sorry.
There. Okay.
Better now?
Yeah.
Okay. So,
as a surrogate, have you ever seen, using
genetic mice with the different
genetic construct that you did, if mice indeed
ate differently, if the food consumption was
impaired in mice?
Oh, what they... Okay. So you're asking if on these drugs, the
mice
change their diet?
Yes.
Yeah. So they don't have a choice,
right? They
get the food.
Not change the diet, but if the food consumption-
Ah.
... was different.
So, when they're on the drugs, we monitor their weight very
carefully. And so,
in other contexts, we know that mice lose a lot of weight,
and it's usually not with drugs. It's usually with genetic deletions.
And we haven't
done
the metabolic stuff, the consumption. We just have monitored weight.
And actually, for cabozantinib, they don't lose any weight.
So
yeah.
Thank you again for a great talk. This is Cheryl from the NCI NIH.
I was thinking how cancer and aging...
Cancer is a disease of aging and vice versa, and a
lot of your data are based on precursor cells.
So if you could comment if these also decline with
age, because the turnover, you mentioned, is every two months.
So is this something that stays within our lifespan, or
does it decline?
No, I think there's very limited data on that.
We had some...
Danny wanted to do an aging project, and I said, "You're a post-doc.
You will never finish." So but he did
find that the number of Wnt-responsive cells in the
circumvallate papilla was decidedly different already,
was diminished at-- And we think those were the progenitor cells,
at 10 months compared to a two to four-month-old adult.
And so I think that is... I'm trying to remember if anyone's
looked at that in terms of
specific
studies. I think taste sensitivity declines in
mice with age,
but mechanistically, all I know is there
may be fewer progenitors that are Wnt sensitive.
Yeah, thank you. That was a great talk.
So I just was wondering if,
in the taste bud cells one, two, and three, do you see any
signatures of GPCR proteins?
Of who?
Of GPCR proteins.
Oh.
So in terms of the signaling or in-
Both ways, signaling and also their-
... transduction. Oh, yeah. So, there's the
cell, theReceptors for sweet and bitter and
umami, those are all GPCRs. And they are
seven-pass transmembrane receptors.
Sweet cells are obligate.
Sweet receptor is obligate heterodimer of TAS1R2
and TAS1R3, et cetera, and the TAS2Rs are bitter
sensors.
Does that answer your question?
And do you see any relation between...
Are they event-driven, and do you see a similar relation
when you
inhibit kit?
I'm sorry, what?
So the signatures-
Oh, inhibit kit.
See, yeah. No, that's a really good idea.
So we lose the TAS1R2,
right? We lose TAS1R2, and we lose, at least in organoids,
we lose other markers.
But what we haven't seen is if there's...
So
this makes me... We can talk about this but-
Yeah. Sure
... but it makes me think about the fact that kit may be
actually doing more than just transducing sweet
in our system.
Yeah. Thank you so much.
Have you looked at Paxlovid, which is the COVID drug that
actually has pretty rapid onset of dysgeusia?
Yeah. So yeah. I took it
at one point, early days, and it was awful.
It was very bitter, and I don't know.
So there are some
drugs, like metformin, I think actually accumulates in the
salivary gland, and so you're bathing your tongue in a bitter
drug. So there's that, and I don't know if Paxlovid behaves that
way,
or if it harkens back to this bitter or
metallic taste.
Just to follow up on what you said before about how things
change from a two-month-old to a 10-month-old.
Yeah.
I just wanted to ask if you could comment then on
your organoid-derived models.
Because if these are from adult patients, maybe they're
not really reflecting...
And if they also have cancer, maybe something else.
Yeah. So,
the way that we obtain these are from
organ donors.
So they're tissue. They're people that have,
they put organ donor on their driver's license.
And so we are able to harvest circumvallate papillae
from these people within 12 hours of being
taken off life support.
So we can't pick our patients, but we do know they
don't have cancer. That was an option.
We were talking to head and neck surgeons about getting
resected tongues from cancer patients that have tongue tumors,
and
I think the issue there is many of those patients receive
radiation therapy and chemotherapy in advance of surgery to shrink the
tumor. And it just seemed like there were so many
confounding
factors that it would be difficult for us to
compare across
individuals. So you're right, with the ones that we have now, we have
men and women,
and they're all under 50 years old.
And so far, I think you have to be 18 to be an organ donor, and so
our youngest donor has been 21.
Hi, thanks for the talk. I have a question.
It's that since the taste bud cells come back every two
months,
so I was wondering, will the smell or the taste come back
just naturally after some time of the chemotherapy?
So,
I don't know anything about smell.
So I don't know anything about smell. Yeah.
But with taste, so it's interesting.
So I think
mice that get hedgehog, a smoothened
antagonist,
right? So
Archana did this study, actually.
So they put mice on the drug long enough to know the taste buds were gone,
took the mice off the drug, and watched the taste buds come back.
And the ones that came back, came back fully, but not all of them did.
And they were looking in the fungiform field,
not in the circumvallate field.
And I've
anecdotally talked to one colleague who's a radiation oncologist
that treats head and neck cancers, and she had a patient
that she treated repeatedly with both
head and neck radiation, but also with
smoothened antagonists. And that person
gradually just lost their sense of taste. It just never came back.
So I think,
yes, it can come back, but I think that
it also doesn't come back the way it was before.
And it may be how the brain adapts to the new taste array,
and if there's enough plasticity for you to limp along with that level
of a taste periphery, then taste seems normal.
Alternatively,
there are head and neck cancer patients that have a permanently
disrupted sense of taste, and anecdotally they say,
"Yes, I can taste everything, but it doesn't taste like it used
to." So they're very aware of that, and what's interesting about
that is that that's not detectable
with these conventional taste and smell tests
that patients are given because they taste just fine.
It's the composite that is distorted for them.
That's very interesting. Thank you.
Thanks.We are
at time.
Well, thank you, Linda. Thanks for the question.
Okay. Thanks, everybody. This is clearly a very engaged group because you could
be out at happy hour, but you've decided to stay here with us.
So we're really, really grateful for that.
Now, I wanted to start by thanking Dr.
Palmer as well for getting us here together.
I've traveled all the way from Melbourne in Australia.
I don't know if there's any other Australians in the audience.
No, I'm glad for you because I nearly had as much time in the air as I will have on
the ground.
And so that flight is no joke. But as I said, it's really, really
great to be here. And to hear someone in the room say that this
wasn't part of their world until they've just come here, and now they understand
about this is our kind of dream come true.
So,
I've been working to bridge chemosensory and clinical oncology
worlds for 15 years. I trained originally as a dietician,
and my PhD was born out of a frustration I had
to
not be able to help my patients as much as I wanted to.
And so I would hear people, especially in the head and neck cancer setting,
complain about taste dysfunction and problems that were getting in the way of them
having an adequate diet and enjoying their food.
And so it led me to undertake a PhD exploring the influence
of chemotherapy on taste dysfunction, nutritional intake, and food
enjoyment.
And what you'll hear today is some of the learnings from that journey over
the last 15 years. But we didn't ask who was in the room, and
so I think we've got a mix of clinician researchers, but
maybe we just see a show of hands if you describe yourself just
as a pure researcher, no one lets you near a patient.
Okay.
A few researchers. And what about clinicians?
You treat patients, you see patients. Okay, good.
And what if you do both?
Everyone. Well, most people, thank you, delve into both worlds.
So we've got a good mix of people, which is wonderful.
Okay.
At the moment, I work in three key areas.
It's gynecological cancer policy, women's
health research, and my passion area, which is gastronomy.
And I think I might be one of the only people in the world who have a
Masters of Dietetics and a Masters of Gastronomy.
So, the food science and the love of food come together nicely.
Okay. So what are the problems in cancer care?
Well, we know that
sensory and hedonic changes are common, but no one's talking about them.
And when we do talk about them, we don't really know how to treat them.
And so it is such that these issues aren't
really prioritized in the pre-treatment setting, in the pre-habilitation
setting. When we tell people what to expect from cancer treatment, we talk to them
about nausea, about hair loss, about weight loss.
But taste dysfunction and smell issues do not
routinely come up in that context.
And so when these things do come up, people are taken
unaware. They're also not necessarily found in isolation.
So, taste and smell problems go together with nausea, with
changes in appetite. And in speaking with colleagues at Fox
Chase Center, what they described is that their
nutrition counseling referrals come from a point of weight loss and
malnutrition. So their counseling referrals, sorry, for taste
dysfunction and how they note that.
So what that means is it's often not until a patient is experiencing
malnutrition risk or malnutrition that they then get counseled and what
comes out of that session is that, "Oh, we've got problems with the way that food
tastes." So,
we're not being proactive about it, and
it is confusing for patients. And there's a really neat term, it's a
terrible term, it's quite depressing, but a term that Santini gave
to the cluster or symptoms that happen in isolation called orphan
symptoms. And these are symptoms that aren't routinely or
spontaneously
mentioned by patients, and they're not routinely assessed by clinicians, and so
they remain unaddressed in a clinical oncology setting.
There's an ESMO guideline for the clinicians in the room
on this. And some of the other symptoms in that
subset include ubiquitous symptoms that aren't life-threatening
but are really bothersome. So things like coughing, like hiccupping,
restless leg syndrome. And you can see by
mentioning those that it's no surprise they don't feature in a hierarchy of
symptoms. But they are symptoms that do cause
great bother to people. We know that food is not only a source of
nutrition, but it's a way of understanding the world and it's
about cultural identity. And so during cancer treatment, those shifts
in food's role from a source of enjoyment to perhaps a source of
medicine or treatment is quite a significant shift.
These problems are underreported.
Like I said, when they do come up, there's confusion about what the referral
pathway should be. So Alyssa Nolden and colleagues published a paper
recently, where clinicians were interviewed.
What do you do when chemosensory issues arise?
Who do you refer to? And there was a diversity in those referral pathways.
They include dentists, dieticians, acupuncturists,
otolaryngologists, I think I've said that right,
and taste and smell centers. So, this isn't the fault of clinicians, but
it's painting the picture that we don't know what to do.
We don't treat these symptoms very well at all.
And because what I'll go on to explain is because we don't accurately
identify the issue at hand, we can't go on to design
and test interventions like we would for some of the other symptoms.
And so there is a lack of evidence for these long-term clinical
interventions that are successful and things happen more by trial and
error.So
fast forward 15 years, and I went and spoke to
clinicians or the nutrition department really at Australia's
leading cancer hospital,
and wanted to know what current practice is.
Are people talking about taste and smell problems?
How is it being discussed with patients? What's being documented?
How are you managing this in practice?
And I sat with the manager and she showed me a tool, which I'll show you
in a moment. It's our standardized PGSGA.
It's a patient-generated subjective global assessment, a validated tool
for assessing
nutrition in oncology patients. And there's
a whole range of tick boxes, have you lost weight? What have your symptoms been?
And there's a whole range of those, and one of them includes that things taste or
smell funny.
So I'll show you that now. You can see that one circled there.
So, there's some weight history, and then there's the types of symptoms that people
are occurring that might have contributed to that change in weight or
nutrition risk. And so
this form is uploaded into the electronic medical record.
And we looked at a patient's and they didn't have that box ticked, and I said to
the manager, "Is the box not
ticked because they didn't have that symptom or that the dietician
didn't ask?" And she said, "It could be either."
In a rush, in a time-pressed environment, people talk about oral
health, they talk about weight loss, they talk about nausea.
Taste and smell falls further down the priority list.
And so we don't have good data in the electronic
medical record either,
because in time-pressured environment, often it's
deprioritized.
The patient education material that's provided is quite generic.
So we know that nutrition is very important in cancer.
And in Australia, the Cancer Council Australia is our
biggest charity providing evidence-based supportive care
information to patients. And there's a nutrition and cancer booklet.
It's 60 pages long.
It's available via PDF. It's free.
And within that, there's a page and a half on taste and smell problems in it.
I wrote that 15 years ago. That is still the resource that is being used in
Australia. And it's very generic, like I said,
but it's something, because 15 years ago, I feel like I went on a bit of
a PR campaign to kind of tell people all about this issue that
one of us in the room has discovered for the first time today.
And there was this awakening, and an education, and a bit of a groundswell I felt
in people understanding the difference between taste and flavor and chemosensory
and other hedonic issues. Hedonics being the study of things that are
pleasurable in life.
And people had these questions. Clinicians had the questions.
Patients had the questions. How long is this thing going to last for?
And someone asked that today. Really practical questions.
I'm saving a really special bottle of wine for when I finish my treatment.
Doctor, when should I expect to be able to drink that?
When should I have this special dinner?
These are the questions people want to know.
And unfortunately, clinicians were at a loss and
would either give false hope by saying, "Well, it should come back when chemo comes
back." Or, "As the chemo stops," rather.
Or, "I don't know, but hopefully it's transient." And so that was part of what we
really wanted some evidence about, and I'll go on to tell you what
I saw.
How many people in the room know about miraculin or something called miracle fruit?
These two do, of course. Good. So I'm not telling you something you don't know.
Please don't rush out and think this is a miracle cure despite its name.
But it is one of these things that
often is done in desperation by clinicians.
And, a decade ago, I wrote a paper entitled,
Taste, in inverted commas because taste is not taste as we saw,
is a Problem for Patients and their Clinicians.
And miraculin is a tropical fruit that the seed of
which when it's sucked
transfers or...
What's the word I'm looking for? It basically changes taste perception, so things
move from tasting sour to tasting sweet.
And so on the tropical fruit farm in Australia, when I experienced this firsthand,
we were all asked to do an experiment and bite into a piece of lime.
Of course, it's very sour. It's astringent. It's quite puckering.
And then you suck on this seed out of the miracle fruit, and then you bite the lime
again and it's sweet. It's as sweet as lemonade.
And this has been extracted into a tablet form.
The dieticians at this hospital are suggesting it at a loss for patients.
"Well, there's no evidence for it, but maybe try this available in the pharmacy
downstairs." The problem we have is that this causes a new problem.
This is about othering. Then suddenly everything tastes sweet.
Who wants their coffee to taste like sweet lemonade? I don't.
But people are desperate, and they're trying things.
Zinc supplementation in Santini's paper.
She reviewed the evidence of therapeutic interventions.
It was not found to be effective. By all means, if someone's deficient in zinc,
that's not good for them, that they should be supplemented.
But there is no wonder drug here. And so what she concluded in that
paper, in that clinical guideline, is that nutrition counseling and self-management
strategies for patient is the best that we can do right now.
So what do we know?
Let's talk about the timing issue.
In a group of people receiving chemotherapy for breast
cancer who were radiotherapy naïve,
we found that these symptoms were cyclical.
So what that means is that within an individual chemotherapy
cycle, the symptoms will change.
Originally or most commonly, patient's taste is assessed on the
day they come back for chemotherapy and present at the hospital, which is usually
two weeks or three weeks from the last chemotherapy cycle that they had.
And what we see is that that's normally when symptoms are at their worst,
sorry, at their least problematic.
They've had two or three weeks for things to resolve somewhat, whereas in those
first four to seven days, it's when
... the most acute problems were. And so in my study, I was able to
post out a taste assessment kit for patients to do at home with me, guided
over the phone. And it was very clear that in days four to seven of a chemotherapy
cycle, that taste dysfunction occurs more
severely than on the last day of a cycle before you start again.
We also saw in that group of people that two months after
chemotherapy had finished, that they were able to identify
the basic tastes again. So tastes had largely normalized.
However,
they had not received any radiotherapy, and that could
be for some people a year after treatment had started.
So they'd battled with these symptoms for an entire year.
People were losing weight but also gaining weight in that cohort,
from as much as 10 kilos in an individual person.
And what patients were telling me is that sometimes they bring an eating event
forward. So how does their diet change? It changes in a whole range of ways.
It may be that people are eating less and not enjoying their food as much.
Some people are actually bringing their food events forward to try and get rid of a
metallic mouth to manage their symptoms of nausea through sort
of dry, crunchy, salty, savory snacks, that kind of thing.
We know, I guess we might call it eating hygiene. We talk about sleep hygiene.
What is good practice? Having a good, clean, healthy mouth
is a good thing to be able to do. And so that
is something that really worked for patients, or at least
it was worse when there wasn't good oral hygiene there.
We talk about a colleague, Sara Spinelli from the University of
Florence in the School of Sensory Science there. I love this term.
She talks about sensory-nutritional opportunities.
So we haven't tested interventions that work, but what we
do know from patients' stories is that some things work for
some people, and we need to hang on to that and we need to test.
We need to
collect data around those things. We need to go back. We need to monitor.
We need to change our practice. And there's a collection of things that
are useful and equally Valentina talked about some of those.
In my study, we saw, I tested a standardized sweet food and a
standardized savory food at different points during the chemotherapy
treatment trajectory, and people went off sweet foods
more often, or more so than they went off savory
foods. And so what do we prescribe to patients who aren't eating during cancer
treatment? These really intensely sweet nutrition supplements.
Jacqueline
Di Meglio in the University of Florence, who's just graduated.
She's, I think, the only other dietician in the world I know with a taste PhD.
Asked patients a question
around which sensory characteristics should food products have
or asked a research question
to improve the eating experience of cancer patients.
And she gave people a forced choice
question around the ideal snack. What must the ideal snack
have and what must it not have? And the answer was that it must
be crunchy, it must be salty, it must be tasty.
It must not be milky, soft, sweet. So
these are common preferences we have.
In my study, ginger was a very
common effective thing that gave a taste sensation for people
who were feeling that it was blunted. It can also help with nausea.
Again, they're patient stories, but they're not to be discounted.
They're the best that we've got.
Okay. So what know-do gaps exist? We know that chemosensory
problems are common, and they do get reported when we ask, but we don't routinely
ask. We know taste is not taste. I'm going to talk about that more in a
minute,
and about words used to match the problem to the intervention or the
self-management technique we suggest.
Being forewarned is to be forearmed, but we don't routinely let patients know what
to expect. We're not doing very well, are we?
And some strategies are experienced by helpful by some patients, but we don't test
and evaluate them.
And so I want to introduce here Boltons Taxonomy of Taste.
Isn't that cute? I don't have a building named after me.
I named a taxonomy after me, and I had to do it myself,
but there it is.
And where this framework comes from, it's modeled off
physicians' work in the 1970s around the taste of pain.
Melzack and Jorgensen used patient descriptors to
help provide hints for the pathophysiological basis of the pain that
a patient was describing. Was it throbbing pain, tingling, stabbing,
burning pain? And so I used this kind of idea
by matching what patients were describing to give hints
about what it is we're actually dealing with here, because taste is not taste,
remember. So patients talk about food tasting like cardboard.
It's quite trite to say there isn't a basic taste of cardboard,
and I don't know how many of you have tasted and been on a cardboard diet.
But in all seriousness, what this is more about is about
mouth feel, about
texture,
about oral hygiene and oral dryness.
People talked about food tasting pins and needley.
This is about chemothesis that
Dr. Palmer talked about. And people have talked about food,
of course, lacking flavor, that muted sensation when you had the pegs on
your noses. And so I'm going to go on to show you how this work's
been bulked out to guide clinicians to then guide
patients, because we can get much more specific than some of the
generic things we tell patients to do, like drink out of a straw because it
bypasses the taste buds and
taste isn't as strong. That's not true.
I mean,
my scientist colleagues will tell us that.
Okay, so in the link down the bottom there, I know no one's from Australia,
but EvIQ
is a portal that's used in Australia to
stockpile clinical guidelines for cancer clinicians.
It includes things like safe administration of chemotherapy.
And it includesA guideline on
taste and smell dysfunction that, again, I developed 15
years ago. So I'm just going to talk to you a little bit about what's in here.
This is an excerpt in the patient education component of that
guideline, and like I said, it's freely available.
So we're using the patient descriptor that food tastes bland, or
it all tastes the same, or it tastes of nothing, or it lacks flavor.
And so that is likely to be an issue with taste sensitivity and
taste intensity. And then there's some definitions of what that
actually is, and then there's some information for patients and self-management
strategies. So for example,
and this is a trial and error bit, if food does taste too salty, try using
low-salt or no-salt alternatives to regular items.
If food tastes too sweet, try substituting breakfast cereals with no added
sugar, for example, oats instead of fruit-sweetened cereal.
And it sounds a bit basic and a bit boring, but in
the context of someone being really unwell and overwhelmed with a whole range of
symptoms and
treatment coming down the line, these are things that can be quite helpful to be
reminded of. But we don't follow up necessarily. How did that go?
How were the oats substituted with the breakfast cereal?
And capture that data and kind of
work out a greater sort of evidence base about what
is most effective. But it is very individually specific.
So again, not a criticism, just an observation.
So what then? These questions remain unanswered.
How should chemosensory function best be assessed in clinical practice?
Which interventions are most effective for treating these problems in the cancer
setting? When are the best opportunities to provide this education to patients,
and how do we best apply a virtuous cycle where clinical and
research data continuously guides practice?
And so what I mean by that is, in the EMR,
capturing the data, having MDT sessions where
clinicians and researchers are in there together.
We're kind of saying, "This is what happened with the patient.
This is what we tried instead. This is how we modified our practice.
This is what the result was."
I feel a clinical guideline coming on.
These are my hobby questions. You might have questions in the audience.
If anyone's interested in answering these questions, come and talk to us.
But from the three areas of my work life at the moment, to what extent do
taste and smell problems present uniquely or differently in women and
men? And then how can those differences be explained and guide
policy and practice or the non-differences?
GLP-1 inhibitors are increasingly
prescribed in the cancer context as well for both
prevention of cancer treatment and as a prehabilitative
component of cancer treatment, especially in cancers
where we know there's a link between clinically defined obesity and
cancer risk and poorer outcomes. And the one that I'm working on at the moment
in Australia is uterine cancers. I think it's called womb cancers here
in the US.
And medical oncologists in my institution
are
prescribing these drugs for cancer patients in that context.
How does the microbiome contribute to taste perception, and how does diet influence
this in the cancer context? And you might have other questions, and I think there
was two QR codes. So one at the start where you could pose your questions.
You can come up to the mic and ask questions there too.
But also, and we'll put this slide up right at the end again.
Valentina started with a slide that had a QR code on it, and really this session
has been our attempt, again, to bridge globally
these chemosensory and clinical oncology worlds.
And so if you have questions, we want to establish a new
community of practice, if you like, to investigate those, so you can upload your
questions and stay in touch via that route.
Okay, so there was lots of depressing stuff, but what can we do now in practice?
Talk about taste to your patients.
Make better use of that routine data if there's dashboards and things like that.
Valentina talked about incorporating it into Epic, into the EMR.
Work with patients and individuals. What's worked for you?
What can you still enjoy? What should we modify?
And revisit that.
Do not provide false hope. As a clinician, it's very tempting to want to give
all the answers. Sometimes it's okay to say we don't know. We don't know.
This is still under investigation, but we want to work with you as a patient to
understand what works best for you, and that might also help other people.
And promote the importance of oral care.
Where to next? We're going to collate and progress these additional questions.
Like we said, I'd recommend applying a learning health system approach
in your clinical institution. If anyone's doing that, I'd love to know and
work with you on it. Testing and validating Botong's taxonomy is a bit of a
pipe dream that I've got. If anyone's interested in doing that, get in touch with
us. And definitely needing to close those know-do gaps in time when we've got
more evidence through the development of clinical guidelines.
We want to stay in touch with you. I think I've said that, and maybe as we finish
now, we'll put
back Valentina's first slide if we can,
and we can have some conversations ongoing.
So if there's any questions for me specifically or for the panel now,
I think you have five minutes to happy hour.
We'd love to hear from you.
Hi. Thank you so much for the excellent talk.
So I think the message that we have heard so
far is that chemosensory issue affects a lot of cancer
patients, but it's not talked about.
Maybe there is not a lot of funding in this space from
federal agencies, so on. And so I'm just wondering, for the
average patients, or not really average, there are some
patients who have access to dieticians, and there are
also many, maybe they're just too busy, maybe they don't have the
resources, so they're just going online and searching for answers.
And so this is kind of the question that I was asking earlier
around ChatGPT as well. What are the...
tools that's available so that patients without leaving
their home can have answers or can have
some counseling. I saw that there were some kind
of self-empowerment tools that you mentioned, but those
might take some level of health literacy-
Yeah
... for patients to understand. I wonder if you could talk about that.
Yeah, absolutely. I would not support people
to go into AI and look for this stuff.
I don't think it exists in the best
scientific, credible kind of sources, let alone through a
bot.
So I don't practice in this country,
so
one thing that we can do and that we will do with people who sign up and use that
QR code is that we can send links to resources that are
patient-centered that exist in the US.
The one in Australia I speak about is Cancer Council Australia, so I
guess it's the
American
Association. No.
I'm in the wrong part of the world, and I forget at this moment.
But the ACS, the American Cancer Society,
will have patient education
materials.
It's generic information. Valentina might have some more suggestions.
I think for the US, going to charities that work-
Mm
... with smell and taste patients, I think that's the first idea.
They know very well about smell and taste, that they have representative from the
cancer community. And in the US, the
STANA, Smell and Taste Association of North America, is
the reference. I have other charities around the
world, in the UK in particular, that are very well-organized around
this, and if you write me an email, I'm happy to give you the
direct contacts.
Right. I think the one very real kind of noted gap that patients
face is that they don't know these places.
So I'm interested, and I have the resources and I have
the health literacy to be able to search.
But I think in reality, whether we support or not, patients are
going to ChatGPT and various places, social media.
They're going to influencers to ask these questions.
So
that's the reality and
what can you do to help these patients if that's where the real
patients are?
I agree. So I think this is the case for every cancer symptoms.
People are googling what to do about my hair loss, et cetera.
I worked for a cancer charity in Australia for a long time, and the best thing we
can do is educate the clinicians that these resources exist so they can tell their
patients about them. You're absolutely right.
The patients need to know how to find these things in the first place.
And I guess, that is a problem we know.
Everyone's an expert on diet. You read a magazine, you kind of Google things.
But this is really credible information, and so it's about getting the right
information to the right patient at the right time.
More work should be done on that.
Thank you.
Someone coming up to the mic over here. Thank you.
Yeah. Just focusing on smell and taste and
not taking away oncology,
implications of COVID on smell and taste
resulting in malnutrition.
What is the kind of the
pathophysiology,
and
kind of helpful guidance?
Million-dollar questions.
Yeah.
I don't know. Yeah, I am live. So
the problem is,
is mice don't get COVID,
right? So the ACE2 receptor in mice does
not permit-- It's not a SARS-CoV-2
receptor, and I guess people have tried to do work in humanized mice.
But mice still can get cells infected but can't
replicate the disease. So I think we're left with
understanding what's going on with people,
and my understanding, at least with olfactory epithelium, is
there is kind of permanent for people that report
prolonged
hyposmia or parosmia, distorted
smell, that
you can biopsy the olfactory epithelium and compare
to people that don't have smell dysfunction or had
COVID but don't have prolonged smell
dysfunction. The normosmic people look pretty good, and
then the long COVID people have disturbed
epithelium. Similarly, a paper just came out from
Colorado, in collaboration with several other people,
looking at biopsies of taste epithelium, taste buds
in patients that report
long
COVID symptoms of taste dysfunction.
And those patients also have the epithelium is distorted.
Now,
mechanistically,
why taste buds are lost and why they aren't coming
back in some patients, whereas they are
coming back in other people that had longer COVID.
So it's just so variable, it's hard to do a really good experiment
to test one idea.
Do
you have-
No, we're trying. We don't know why people lose their
sense of smell to COVID, at least clearly, and why they
get it back. We just got funded a project to
actually study that and build olfactory organoids, taste organoids
from humans, as well as phenotyping broadly, because that's an
open question. We do know that people after two years, four
years, five years, they still have not gotten back their sense of smell.
There's a risk factor of multiple infections on the same
people. So there's a vulnerability, but we haven't identified
exactly which factors
are the driving ones right now. Part of this, and going also to
how do we educate patients, these are complex system.
Olfaction is the only system where we don't know exactly how we go from
chemistry to perception yet,
and it's complicated, like it's a high-dimensional sense,
complicated to talk about, in a sense, with low awareness.
So the barrier is really starting talking about it.
Like that step one is really just mention this.
Without all of the nuances, just a checkbox, there's some
smell and taste. It's okay to lump it together to start with,
and then when more information becomes available, a mechanism we're going
to be able to refine. But having the conversation, I would say is
step one for all of us.
Thank you.
Well, thank you all. Unless there are other
questions, we're going to stay around for a couple of minutes, happy to chat, but
we really are grateful for you engaging with us so
wonderfully and spanning across several topics.
So, we're available. Connect with us.
We really want to continue this conversation.
And thank you, of course, to the speakers and to the audience.
Thank you.
Thanks.